This problem takes place in Florence, Italy.
The Duomo is a famous cathedral in Florence, Italy.
In this problem you are going to calculate the height of the Duomo.
You'll calculate this height based on these dimensions,
which I've given you here, as well as the fact
that at a certain time of day the sun strikes just right,
so that one of the sun's rays, which just grazes the tip of the spire here
will also just graze the corner of this part of the building
and land right into this man's eye.
Use these dimensions, use this fact about the sun's ray,
and tell me the height of the Duomo.
Enter your height here in meters,
and remember the height is the full distance from this tip all the way down to the bottom.